this question was submitted by a member
of the electrical and electronics
engineers magnetics community the
question is is spin quantum computing
feasible very difficult to answer to
this question if you ask is a question
to people walking on project of quantum
computers often as I say I don't know
they say I don't know I talked with
several big names since this field and
generous I say ok the physic is
beautiful is very innate as in projects
to to replace conventional computing by
quantum computing but we don't know if
it will be very feasible and certainly
not a chop there may be after 20 years
something like that